anyone who's ever watched an episode of
Law & Order probably knows what a
criminal trial jury is 12 people who
have to decide whether someone is guilty
or innocent there are lots of eloquent
speeches from a prosecutor and a defense
attorney you know like Atticus Finch in
to kill a mockingbird but seriously what
the fuck is a grand jury grand juries
happen before a criminal trial think of
the prosecutor here as the master of
ceremonies he or she basically takes the
evidence the jury hears and the defense
attorney has no say there's also usually
no judge grand juries have to decide
whether or not there's enough evidence
just to accuse or charge someone with a
crime this is called indictment grand
juries don't have to decide whether the
crime was committed or whether the
accused is guilty that's safe for a
trial 23 states in DC require grand
juries there can be anywhere from five
to twenty three jurors at the state
level and 16 to 23 at the federal level
usually only the most serious crimes
like rape or murder go to a grand jury
lots of people have argued that grand
juries have become a mere formality or
worse a prosecutor's best friend out of
162,000 federal cases in 2010 grand
juries didn't come up with an indictment
in just 11 of them but it wasn't always
so grand juries are actually really old
some have traced them as far back as
ancient Greece others to the
anglo-saxons more than 10 centuries ago
the actual term grand jury was used back
in 1386 when a sheriff rounded up 24
nights to present offenses committed in
the county grand juries evolved in
England from there and the practice was
imported to the American colonies in
1734 three grand juries refused to
indict John Peters anger he was charged
with sedition for publishing stuff there
was critical of the governor of New York
which helps explain why a few years
later American revolutionaries thought
grand juries were a very good thing the
founding fathers enshrined the grand
jury in the Constitution seeing it as a
shield against unjust persecution so now
that you know more about grand juries
what do you think antiquated relic or
essential tool for justice